hey conan here again and we're trying to
raise money for a good cause on the
holidays
get together foundation great way to
help children during the holiday season
donate there should be information at
the bottom of the screen
if there isn't i'll fire the person
responsible on christmas eve that's the
kind of guy i am
all right i got some great people
handling this today with me
mr jimmy vivino we got uh james the worm
wormworth what an awful nickname on
drums and then mike merritt
on uh on the bass guitar and then
helping us out skills
is going to play that jingly jangly
thing went uh yes
nine years of music college for that
anyway
there are only two great christmas songs
in the world we all know that
one of course handles messiah the other
by the kinks
let's try that second one doctor take us
[Music]
away
[Music]
when i was small i believed in santa
claus
though i knew it was but i would hang up
my stockings at christmas
hoping my presence and not be found
was the last time i prayed for christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give us some money
[Music]
to the little rich one
[Music]
don't give my brother a steve austin
outfit don't give my sister a coffee toy
we don't wanna take solo monopoly
[Music]
[Music]
don't mess around with those silly toys
he's got lots of mouths to feed but if
you've got one i'll have a machine gun
so i can scare all the kids on the
street
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
have yourself a very merry christmas
have yourself a good time
but remember the kids who got nothing
while you're drinking down you want
[Music]
father christmas give us some money
we got no time for your silly toys
father christmas
please hand it over we'll beat you up so
don't make us a noise
[Music]
to the little rich
[Music]
you